it's III Scott you and I saw Star Wars
Battlefront Bespin DLC did it was pretty
cool it was yeah I mean it's nice to get
you know adding more areas to the game
it's always great to get you know new
stuff from the movies new familiar
things sure the first area that we
played was actually just sort of like
not as iconic as some of the other
levels that we've seen in the game so
far it was just sort of an open
cityscape kind of areas like the outdoor
spaces of the city that you actually
don't see too much of yeah in the movies
but it does add like a really
interesting open area to the game it's a
very very large map a lot of pieces of
cover but still just for the most part
very open sure yeah skyscrapers make it
really interesting you know everything
else I feel like in the game has just
terrain this is very much an urban
environment so yeah you know you get a
new vehicle the Bespin Cloud car yeah
and like you said the sky scrapers make
it really interesting having to like
traverse through those environments
because you can absolutely crash into
any of those buildings I did many time
yeah so definitely makes dog fighting a
little more interesting because you're
not just flying around in open space you
can actually maneuver around obstacles
or try to like you know it's easier to
lose somebody or lure them into a sort
of an area that will be harder for them
to escape from yeah it definitely adds a
very interesting dynamic to the way the
vehicles work yeah was pretty fun i mean
i was doing cool stuff with to like
going under bridges you know getting a
TST kills by hugging a skyscraper yeah I
mean that was pretty fun I think that's
nice to see that happen opposed to all
these other maps which are fairly open
right as far as dog fighting go so yeah
you get to like really change it up
nicely there I would sit any time I came
up against an 80 80 when I was on foot
like I they was just destroyed me it was
very hard to get away because most of
the map is so open you can kind of
crouched behind cover and pray but they
know you're there they can just wait if
you ever move they can just take you out
so absolutely that was kind of a bummer
especially when you like our force to
cross the street like it you just don't
have enough yeah I cover having quite a
bit on that map because I mean there
were some stretches which is like there
is no cover for enough space that if a
vehicle has seen you you're just toast
the apt is unfortunate but the other
area super cool is that this DLC also
includes the sort of cryo chamber where
we see Luke bite Darth Vader for the
very first time where Han is frozen in
carbonite so seeing that and feeling
just it's so authentic it's walking to
the movies it was I immediately felt you
know just completely connected to this
area so cool to see it rendered so
truthfully so faithfully oh yeah yeah
easily when the most impressive maps
that game has to offer a lot of scenes
on moments from the movie that you
actually kind of get to experience like
Luke coming into that tube corridor
where that like a gate door open still
open yeah you know it's got yep course
come on lights turn on it it was really
I can run through that it feels so cool
right in addition of being like you know
just feeling very cool being in this
movie space it's actually pretty cool
map as well I mean there are some really
tight hallways and corridors but then it
opens up into a larger room where like
the freezing chamber actually is so it's
a relatively intricate map and I think
actually a pretty cool addition to
what's already in the game definitely uh
we also get in this DLC to new heroes
yes very important I played Lando for
about five seconds until I got just
crushed by a name that'll happen ACAT
but dengar was a pretty cool hero he yes
one of his like abilities as he just
like can just basically go on insane
full auto and it's just posed this one
yeah this thing is just flying around
and then he can throw like a dozen
remote mines or just mines actually out
of people he was pretty fun I'll soak up
of new weapons not quite as exciting as
the heroes but there's like a night
sniper pistol that has like when you aim
down sight if the screen goes black and
white you can kind of see like the glowy
sort of white outlines of any enemies we
were playing at his daytime map so it
was really the helpful but it might be
more helpful on darker maps absolutely
yeah what was the other was to say was
on e 40 or e 4 blaster up pretty generic
I mean I don't know a lot of those
weapons does kind of feel the same that
is one of the things that I think battle
foot doesn't do well that well the
weapons are all a little bit samey and
this doesn't really change that all that
much unfortunately but you know Lando
and dengar and the cryo chamber like all
that stuff was really great yeah it was
pretty fun um and that's roughly about
it was near new game mode sabotage new
game mode yeah a bit like rush from from
battlefield so that was really cool I'm
also some new Java quests to get the new
gears up right
a few other things but that was that was
all the big stuff yeah the job stuff was
interesting I mean that's a whole
another way to progress in the game
right you know you get tasked with
challenges and order unlock items and
other depending on the gear that you
want you can pick that specific
challenge exactly but overall he have it
was nice you know if you are into the
battlefront rebound reverse interviewer
Star Wars fan just delivers like more
fan service and absolutely love about
that game yeah cool well thanks very
much Scott absolutely